what's the best screenwriting book
you've ever read
i've never read a screenwriting book but
i've read a lot of screenplays
and that's so funny i've never read a
screenwriting book i've tried and i just
like i can't relate to them but i've
read a ton of screenplays actually since
i was a kid i read screenplays
there used to be this guy in union
square in new york
that would bootleg sell bootleg printed
out copies of the screenplays
um that's great yeah and i remember
buying the goodfellas one and that was
really influential on me when i was a
kid and
taxi driver and um uh
so i was reading all of these
screenplays over time
and uh cone blood simple cone brother
screenplays were really
uh influential and so that's what i
learned from was reading a lot of
screenplays not really books on them and
watching
tons of movies but yeah so this guy i'm
sorry i'm just fascinated but did he
have like a booth set up
oh yeah like a whole table and it would
have like i could see it now like
all these like different screenplays
that were brassed and bound they have
like these
neon yellow or pink like highlighter
colors on the front
and these like bad printouts of the film
so it'd be like the bad vhs cover of
like the godfather
and then it would be the whole script
though it was basically somehow he got
his hands on the script and he would
have them xerox they were like terrible
xeroxes they were like two or three
bucks and i buy them i had stacking them
and
like read them and since i was a young
age that's kind of like
how i got into it and you said
goodfellas was the first one or two
goodfellas is like the first one i
really remember reading
um like from him and then from them and
i still have tons of screenwriting uh
my screenplays that you know i still get
you know i i just was reading the um
the counselor screenplay by cormac
mccarthy which is a film not many people
love
the screenplay is absolutely phenomenal
it's actually see
it almost you could see it as an example
of a screenplay that
is so good it makes it it was too almost
too good to become a movie
you know because it's so well written
why do you think it because it doesn't
there's not enough showing
it well yeah because it's all on the
page like so much if it's on the page
in the screenplay it's in so much if
it's like the inner monologue in the
dialogue
you know he's such a novelist like the
dialogue when it gets spoken
doesn't have the same effect as when you
read it in his screenplay
the way the dialogue just like sits with
you and stings you and just
comes out but i love the film either way
but the
screenplay is really something but yeah
i love reading screenplays but yeah i
never really read
like like save the cat or anything like
that yeah i just
it it's probably why my screenplays are
all a little disjointed
well you know it's funny maybe that's
your next idea is the some guy that's in
you said times square or union square
two union square okay time different
yeah sorry
time square would be amazing i'm
picturing a guy with like a trench coat
that's hey i've got these necklaces here
you know
i mean it's pretty close like it wasn't
far from that he was definitely like
something like haitian dude who was just
like hey screenplay screenplay
screenplay
because like only in new york could that
be some sort of side hustle
i love it oh man that's great
how did you digest it how do you feel
that that was helpful for you
i i didn't really i don't think like
deconstruct them i just kind of
they just sat with me and things that i
and what i loved about it you know like
it
it was kind of like it was just to kind
of get an understanding of the language
and understanding of
of the format and because i loved
most of the screenplays i read i had
seen the movies of so it was kind of
almost like
yeah i guess it was the screenplay
itself is a deconstruction of the film
so it was almost like i got to go
backwards and see where they started
and then i could fill in the blanks of
how they ended up there
and i became really obsessed with like
the lore of how films were made
like i loved reading hollywood stories
or production stories
so i think that became that kind of like
fill in the gap area
but um that's where i kind of a lot of
what i learned from was like watching
movies
and then reading the movies and then
reading how the movies were made
and between that i think i hopefully
picked up a few things
did you see sunset boulevard yeah i love
sunset well queen is very much based off
sunset over yeah
i love sunset boulevard yeah i didn't
find her character that
um horrible i just felt it was a good
representation of you know because she
started what at seventeen
in georgia sort of glorious
and uh i love i love the scenes where
all the photos on the wall and
everything are of her
and that that's her whole world is is
she is did nothing exist outside of that
you know just
yeah there's a great scene where she
goes to the front gate of the studio you
know and they're like who are you like
we're not gonna let you in
and what um will be demille is like
it's glorious swanson you have to let
her in like you know it's like
um and it is amazing that film that
shows that fall from grace and
it's such a great intricacy and you know
they made that film they were writing
the screenplay as they were shooting it
oh wow that they didn't go in with a
full screenplay of that movie billy
wilder and i remember who this co-writer
was
so it's kind of amazing that that film
has this very
improvisational side that you would
never realize
and the way it was made because he's
writing the screenplay too
and sees her as like the meal ticket but
yeah it's
very interesting yeah and then uh what's
her his name who plays her
butler oh he was fantastic yeah he's her
enabler
and he was his direct she he's i can't
remember him forgetting his name right
now the blue angel
max he put it in a cry
okay at some point but uh
he was the uh he was the director and
so he played her butler right it was
also you find out her husband
and in real life he had directed her in
movies
and they had a very like kind of almost
like abusive director actress
relationship
so billy wilder was like almost like an
inside joke for him to put him as the
uh as the subservient to her
interesting right yeah and he also sort
of cleaned up everything and well i
don't want to give away too much but
the letters and everything just sort of
if you have not seen sunset boulevard
stop this interview and go watch
boulevard
you